for nearly a month now pretty much every
college campus in the country has made
it clear that decolonization means
basically kill whitey it's long been
obvious this is always what the left
meant by decolonization as I outlined on
this show a few weeks ago but after
hamas's attack on Israel activist groups
have made it explicit they want similar
murders to happen in this country they
don't view their enemies as human and
they basically want them exterminated
now Fred's part The Establishment left
didn't quite join in on these calls for
violence at least not directly in
explicitly but that's all starting to
change um especially when you look at uh
what was posted online at the outlet
Salon yesterday which passes for
mainstream among leftists I suppose and
it published an oped from a journalist
named Brian carum now in no uncertain
terms the point of this oped is to
justify the dehumanization of
conservatives and in particular
conservative Christians kum's piece is
titled magga and Christian nationalism
bigger threat to America than Hamas
could ever be this article went viral
the other day Elon Musk tweeted about it
a few times caused a lot of outrage what
a lot of people are missing is that this
opet is just the latest iteration of a
long line of op-eds from this same guy
in Salon that accused conservatives of
being terrorists in fact just a month
ago km wrote a piece in Salon entitled
uh Hamas and the GOP are both terrorist
groups it's just a matter of degree now
in that article Kum asserted quote
there's little or no difference between
most of the GOP leadership including Jim
Jordan and Donald Trump and the leaders
of Hamas both groups will do anything
they can to win both groups have engaged
in atrocities both groups continue to
lie both groups use human beings as
hostages both groups are extremely
dangerous both groups threaten to the
world's internal and external peace the
fact is many Americans viscerally
understand this Donald Trump and his
followers are
terrorists and of course you listen to
that you wonder well when has Donald
Trump held people hostage what
atrocities did he
commit as melodramatic and deranged as
that oped was no one paid any attention
to it whatsoever so this week Kum
basically rewrote the same article
except he added a little more bite to it
this time around before I get any
further into specifics of this unhinged
screed um it's important to emphasize a
couple things first of all Kum is not an
intern or a random troll or anything
like that he is the uh he's the former
senior White House correspondent for
Playboy and for years he's been a
credentialed member of the White House
Press pool this is one of the most
coveted positions among mainstream
journalists back when we had
journalistic standards it used to mean
something to be a white house
corespondent but we don't have
journalistic standards anymore and so
Brian carum is free to publish oped
saying that his domestic political
opponents are worse than Hamas
terrorists who kill civilians while
retaining his White House press
credentials in a serious country if you
write something like that you're not
going to be invited into the White House
Press pool but uh again we're not a
serious country the other important
point to emphasize is that while I'm
going to refer to uh kum's writing
specifically in this monologue he's far
from the only prominent figure on the
left who feels this way first of all
whatever editors still work at Salon had
to approve his pieces and publish them
but more to the point the leaders of the
democratic party have been demonizing
their political opponents uh using these
terms and in this way for years and
doing it in ways that are not that
dissimilar to what km is doing it was
just a year ago could forget that Joe
Biden all but declared war on quote
unquote Maga Republicans calling them a
threat to democracy for disagreeing with
him let's uh relive that moment
together too much of what's happening in
our country today is not
normal Donald Trump and the magga
Republicans represent an extremism that
threatens the very foundations of our
Republic now I want to be very clear
very clear up front
not every Republican not even the
majority of Republicans are magga
Republicans not every Republican
Embraces their extreme
ideology I know because I've been able
to work with these mainstream
Republicans but there's no question that
the Republican party today is dominated
driven and
intimidated by Donald Trump and the
magga
Republicans and that is a threat to this
country so there's Joe Biden doing
something by the way that we're used to
it now from him but that is that is
unprecedented and that presidents don't
generally do which is openly demonizing
not just political opponents I mean
that's been done before but but voters
like normal voters magga Republicans of
course include Donald Trump's supporters
and there's millions of
them that's something Donald Trump
himself never did he never demonized
voters and he demonizes or he attacks
people who attack him especially
politicians and celebrities and those
sorts of people he doesn't go after
normal voters Joe Biden does and so
there he is standing in front of the the
Marines with the blood red backdrop
shaking his fists and telling the
country that democracy means voting for
Joe Biden everyone who does who doesn't
vote for Joe Biden by contrast uh is a
terrorist we saw that kind of rhetoric
constantly last year around the same
time as Joe Biden's diet tribe about
magga Republicans various Outlets
including the deli Beast labeled me a
stochastic terrorist they use the same
term to describe lives a Tik Tok and
many others uh and it's a term that
means nothing basically but sounds
vaguely intelligent I guess so you hear
it all the time now it also has very
clear implications you know everyone
instinctively agrees that terrorists
should be killed they're a threat to the
country so when you call someone a
terrorist well it's not hard to connect
the
dots but this Salon piece still stands
out for how blatant and flagrant it is
here's how the piece begins quote the
House of Representatives now run by Mike
Johnson offers a discount version of the
apocalyptic orgasm that Holy Rollers
have dreamed of for years they've
renewed the Inquisition and seem
determined to convert the us into a
theocracy run by people who will thump
you with the Bible but haven't read much
of it now at this point you're probably
wondering where has that happened like
what is he talking about where have
Republicans done anything that could be
remotely compared to the
Inquisition now of course the
Inquisition gets a bad rap anyway but
that's a topic for a different day but
in what way is Mike Johnson ushering in
a theocracy is he proposing uh making
church attendance compulsory has he
tried to pass a law for bidding the
practice of non-Christian
religions has he burned any atheists at
the stake recently as far as I know the
answer is no on all
accounts it appears that he has earned
the label of theocrat simply because
he's a Christian with conservative
political views and that might not seem
like a big deal to you if you're a well
adjusted sane person but the left-wing
media of course is comprised of people
people who are neither of those things
and for a long time now Bri Brian carum
specifically has viewed Christians who
hold conservative political views as
demonic here he was in the White House
Rose Garden just a couple of years ago
during the Trump presidency explaining
that conservatives are quote eager for
demonic possession watch don't be sad
don't be sad no I'm just standing alone
this is a group of people that are eager
for demonic possession
[Laughter]
demonic
calling me now in the White House in the
road you're threatening me in the
road you are a punk you're not a
journalist you're a punk go
home just for the record he'd kick your
punk
ass oh and that's the measure of
everything
[Music]
the real journalist thank you now I'm
not exactly sure what eager for demonic
possession is even supposed to mean to
be honest but um at the time you know a
handful of commentators chastised Brian
carum for acting out they pray Sebastian
Gorka for putting him in his place but
in reality his Outburst was a revealing
moment he was echoing an increasingly
common view on the left which is that
conservatives in particular Christians
uh need to be eliminated they need to be
exercised this is a that wasn't
advertised widely a couple of years ago
but you see it all over the place now a
couple of days ago for example Rolling
Stone ran a detailed hitpiece on Johnson
focusing on his work at Alliance
defending freedom for nearly a decade in
that capacity Johnson Advanced legal
positions that are completely consistent
with his face he opposed his faith he he
opposed sodomy he rejected the Supreme
Court ruling that legalized gay marriage
and he wrote naed predicting correctly
that the so-called lgbtq movement left
unchallenged will be quote the harbinger
of chaos and SE ual Anarchy that could
Doom even the strongest Republic now you
could disagree with Mike Johnson's views
but there's no denying that every single
one of them is consistent with a
Christian worldview he was also
undeniably correct in that prediction as
uh recent events have repeatedly shown
in fact his views are completely
consistent with the Democratic party's
platform Circa about 2006 the 2008
version of Brock Obama wouldn't take
issue with any of
it at least not
publicly and yet back when most people
thought like this across the political
Spectrum we were not living as the media
now predicts in a Theocratic dystopian
Wasteland in fact most people agree
we're living in in uh by almost every
measure a better country everything
going on in the world there's no better
time to build a daily habit of prayer
and meditation building a habit of
prayer can help uh cultivate an attitude
of gratitude focusing on what you're
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
H is the number one Christian Prayer app
in the US it's helped me maintain a
daily prayer routine and it can help you
too download the app for free at
hollow.com Walsh you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start we'll
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the hall app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cavel
even some worldclass athletes with
hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using Hall to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
hallow also just added a section of
their app called prayers for peace for
Israel you can download Hall at hall.com
waling get exclusive three months free
that's three months absolutely free at
hall.com
Walsh now Karen's piece doesn't grapple
with any of this instead in something of
a manic rage he goes on to ramble about
everything from Israel bombing a refugee
camp in Gaza to artificial intelligence
to the dangers of climate change change
quote that is our world today it took an
asteroid the size of a modern city to
wipe out the dinosaurs people being
smarter than dinosaurs have figured out
how to destroy everything all by
ourselves climate change is slowly
creeping up up on us and we are killing
each other at an increasing rate it took
a category 5 hurricane to kill 40 odd
people in aapco last week we killed that
many in two mass shootings in the US in
about the same amount of time and spared
the property Pogo was right we have met
the enemy and he is us now I'll pause
here to note as I did a few days ago
that when the left talks about mass
shootings they love to imply that it's
always quote unquote Maga Republicans
who are doing the shooting get a lot of
mileage out of that but that's almost
never the case in the overwhelming
number of cases including one of the
shootings that Kum appears to be
referencing there these mass shootings
are taking place in overwhelmingly black
neighborhoods more than a dozen people
were shot by a felon at a Halloween
party in Chicago just a couple of days
ago you probably didn't hear much about
that in the media but it did happen
that's a mass
shooting
but we don't talk about it as much
because it's not the result of
Christianity or Christian nationalism or
Trump supporters or Maga
Republicans maybe the reason the media
buries any mention of these mass
shootings in Black communities is that
if they covered them then everyone would
realize what an absurd and
counterfactual talking point all of this
is but even if you accept everything
that Kum says even if you suspend
reality for a second and agree that Maga
Republicans are somehow doing all these
mass shootings it still wouldn't come
close to supporting his thesis which is
that conservatives are terrorist group
that are more dangerous to Americans
than
Hamas there are well over 200 million
Christians in this country if you pulled
those Christians you would find 0%
support for murdering non-believers like
literally 0% there would not be any
enthusiasm at all for gunning down
elderly women at bus
stops by contrast the founding Charter
of Hamas calls for genocide every single
militant of Hamas wants to murder
non-muslims in a particular Jews and as
we've learned recently some of these
militants could easily be entering this
country through the southern
border now of course the media knows
this Brian caram knows that knows that
so do his editors and so does the rest
of the media the reason there will be no
condemnation from anyone from the
leftwing media to the White House Press
courp to the Biden Administration is
that they understand what he's really
getting at here he's not really trying
to make any meaningful point about Hamas
or artificial intelligence or climate
change he's trying to communicate the
same message that Joe Biden did one year
ago except he's putting a finer point on
it and that message is that many on the
left want their political opponents to
be eliminated to die they don't just
want them to lose
elections they don't just want to censor
them they want to dehumanize them
criminalize them and worse a lot
worse hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on annual plans
see you there